hello everyone and welcome to another
interesting game from round three of the
2013 candidates tournament now as you
remember from my video from round one
and round two
lastly one who did not have the greatest
start to the tournament he he drew his
first game against the Alexander group
and then he lost his second game against
team order a job of and the lemon Aragon
had a pretty nice start to the
tournament in round one he drew Magnus
Carlsen and in round two he defeated
Boris Gelfand so vastly has the white
pieces in this game and he would
definitely enjoy breaking 50% after
after round three
so before we start with again we do have
a couple of photos from this round here
is vastly one took before the game
preparing for for a great brawl with 11
Aragon here we have a photo of lemon in
the back you can see a blurry photo of
Magnus Carlsen stretching and here we
have a nice photo of Astley one two
pounding that clock which is kind of
ironic because this game is often one of
the games that will be decided but by
not pounding on the clock but you'll see
what I mean by this so Wesley is white
white and he opens with d4 we have
Knight to f6 Bishop to g5 eventual goes
for the trombone ski attack east six
this is the classical defense to the
Trump offski Knight to d2 and c5 we have
III b6 Knight to f3 Bishop to b7 c3 and
Bishop to e7 Bishop to d3 Aragon castles
and now Bishop captures on f6 this is
only one one of the examples were
Avenger gives up his Bishop air early on
in the game Bishop captures and now h4
so you can see that it's it's only move
9 and the bunch already gave up give up
his bishops pair and played h4
we have Knight to c6 and Knight to g5 so
going all out here this is a vastly
bunch of going full barbarian mode g6
you have to prevent the attack on h7 h6
this is somewhat H second isn't so great
because white doesn't have to react to
this white can simply go Queen to h5 and
the the attack continues for what you
don't really have to get move the night
black can never really capture the night
then you will open open up the H file
and now white is just winning
so after this Knight to g5 g6 by Oregon
we had F 4 9 3 7 and now Queen to g4 so
vastly is putting all of his pieces to
the Kings side h5 Queen to h3 and now C
captor son before he captures on d4 and
now b5 seems like seems like a weird
move but Aaron has some very interesting
ideas about about what happens when
Queen comes to b6 and thus Queen to b6
move will be a crucial idea and in most
of the variations in this game capturing
the pawn doesn't give white anything
Ariane was sibling attack it and to
bring his Queen to b6 even even sooner
so eventually is not interested he plays
a3 we have Queen to b6 and now rook to G
1 here even cook is ready to push g4 and
break open on the Kings side this would
be excellent but our onion doesn't allow
it
Knight to d5 and this was the idea of of
this b5 move and playing Queen to b6 now
you can't push g4 immediately if you
push g4 immediately then Oregon's idea
was a bishop captures on d4 now of
course the rope and g1 is attacked and
after you place C capture screen
captures the problem is
yolk is still attacked on g1 after
something like queenside castle you
could also maybe play rook to f1 to
guard f4 but then H captures on g4 will
be very nice for black but after
queenside castle now you get to Knight
captures on f4 attacking the Queen and
the bishop on d3 and pretty much
anything you do here will be will be
extremely good for black let's say might
be 3 your tag the black queen but now
check King b1 and now you can either
choose either maybe you want to just
capture the Queen and then capture the
rook or you want to capture the rook on
G 1 and then capture the Queen but the
best move is Queen to d5 simply move
your queen out a danger and attack the
knight on b3 and after why does the same
Queen g3 now you simply capture the
knight and the problem is
white can never capture the night on f4
if white captures then you get Bishop to
d5 and there is no defense against Queen
to a - so this will be excellent for
black so this was our engines idea this
b5 Queen b6 and the Knight to d5
so here Avant replayed night to G to e4
we have Bishop to g7 here the same idea
doesn't really apply if you play Bishop
capture song before you can still play
this but after captures captures now
white can in fact play rook to f1
because this pawn is not on g4 there is
no this in-between H captures on g4 and
while this is fine for black that you
don't really have anything decisive so
you don't really want to give up a pawn
in the candidates give up a piece in the
candidates without anything decisive and
instead after Knight to d5 and this idea
Knight d4 by von Schuch
you can go Knight captures on f4 with
ideas like attacking the bishop and the
Queen like an in-between move grabbing
upon because Knight captures on f6 comes
with check now you check here King g7
and now you capture on h5 with check a
knight captures you move the Queen and
always well for white so after this
night g2e 4 by van choke Arielle moves
the bishop back Bishop to g7 and the now
comes Queen to f3 Queen to f3 was an
imprecision that Aragon took advantage
of masterfully after Queen to f3
he played before what's the idea behind
before well first of all you're you're
breaking open on the Queen side I want
trucks king is still in the center he
can no longer castle on the Kings side
and if you break open on the Queen side
then you're pretty much free to attack
the white king so it captures some
before and night capture some before and
what's the idea here the idea is that if
you capture the night then f5 is coming
attacking the knight you can't move the
knight the knight is pinned and this
will be excellent for black so after
night before we have Knight to c4 event
took now attacks are announced Queen on
b6 Queen to b5
we have Knight to e5 attacking the Queen
by the bishop on d3 and now Knight
captures with Czech Knight captures on
d3 and now Queen to f5 still not
allowing a event chip to pull g4 and
also there is a nice pressure on the
night here money for that is currently
attacked twice so Knight d2 c5 attacking
the bishop on b7 and also defending the
knight on e4 Bishop to c6 and now comes
b4 we have rook to b8 and now rook to a5
by Yvonne shook and here this is only
moved 25 but as we've said in the
previous video in round 3 everyone was
in serious time trouble so event was
also in serious time trouble here in in
move 25 and Iranian didn't want to waste
a lot of time here he wanted he wanted
to play fast using his own time and here
arlynn said that he knew that Bishop
captures on d4 was probably winning and
he was in fact right but he didn't play
this because he didn't want to spend too
much time calculating it and then maybe
if it turns out it wasn't winning then
event would also figure out something
but in fact after Bishop captures pawn
captures rook captures the white king is
still in the center you're you're
threatening to grab the d4 pawn you're
threatening rugby 1 you can double rooks
and really cause chaos here for example
if white decides to do something like
king f2 then you simply check in and
after the king runs away
now comes the bishop captures Queen
captures and here you have to run away
with the King to h2 and now Queen h4
will be checkmate one of the variations
that could happen but you definitely
don't want to allow any any rook to be
one ideas so simply rook to a1 about now
rogue capture Sunday 4 and now you're
you have three points for the piece with
a better position so this will be a very
very pleasant to play for black but
Iranian did not want to spend too much
time here so instead he played a6 if I
played Queen to e3 and now we have Queen
to g4 g3 rook to be 5 and now rook
captures on a6 rook captures on a6
Knight captures on a6 and now II five
the idea of Aragon's pawn sacrifice and
E 5 is another excellent breakthrough
arena and found in this game and now
comes D captures on e5 and Bishop
captures on e4
and here here is a wonderful idea
pause the video here and try to figure
out what how why did Arlen play this and
another thing can Queen capture bishop
if the Queen can capture the bishop then
even took is simply down a piece so can
the Queen capture this Bishop and if yes
why yes and if no why no and if you
can't capture the bishop what do you
play then so a lot of players thought
that event you should just resign here
but eventually in fact found a brilliant
idea and well for those of you who found
the idea of congratulations although you
know you were not in time trouble I do
hope you use your time wisely but maybe
some of you just want to enjoy the show
if you play Queen captures on e4 then
rook captures on e5 wins the game
immediately for black your queen is
pinned you can't move the Queen there's
the King anyone black is threatening
rook captures Queen if you capture rook
then Bishop captures Queen use the Queen
and the game if you capture with the
pawn then your queen is undefended on e4
Queen capture screen this way again you
lose the game
so after this Bishop captures any for it
seems like black is completely winning
but event refines this breaking idea c4
c4 and now rook captures an e5 of course
does nothing because there's a bishop
here you can simply capture that rook
and you have to come up with a move the
knight is guarding before the night is
also not allowing the rook to retreat
the b8 you you have to either play rook
to b6 or rope to b7 so what do you play
here if you play something like rook to
b7 then you get Queen captures on e4 and
then the Queen is once again attacking
the rook then you have to retreat rook
to b6 and then after check King moves
and c5 white out of a out of a pretty
terrible position now it's actually
white that's that's pushing here so
after this Bishop captures on e4 and
divine chokes brilliant c4
we have rook to b6 by Oregon now if if I
took captures Bishop then Aragon
captures knight on a six so Aragon is
forcing event you to capture the rook
here so Aragon sacrifices do
change the Queen captures row can be six
this was forced and the now comes Queen
to f3 infiltrating now we want to
position ideas like Bishop to d3
followed by Queen to d2 checkmate
are you know in the air so you do have
to react to this Queen to f2 was played
and now Queen to a3 night to c5 we have
Queen capture some before with check
grabbing a pawn and like we've said
eventual was in serious time trouble and
here he has to find a move this is only
move 35 he has to make move 35 and he
still has to make 35 and all the way to
40 so six moves so five moves to reach
time control and here he played King to
d2 but after he played him to d2 he hit
the clock and he realized that his time
has once again run out so this is the
third round of the candidates tournament
2013 and eventual already lost two games
by running out of time on his flock and
the position here isn't isn't is much
better than it was in his game against
her job of when his time also ran out
here I want to be is actually up the
exchange and well it's it's questionable
if he can survive this Aragon does have
the bishop pair but before this dark
square Bishop is activated somehow as
currently it's it's not doing all that
much it's you know you you have to it
would have to be a precise play by black
to win this but yeah
unfortunately for von Schuch another
game lost on time and event five out of
three so one draw and two losses from
the first three rounds and eleven Aragon
is after three rounds leading the
candidates tournament as he has two wins
and one draw so two and a half points
out of three I will also include an
article in the description below be sure
to check that out it's a very extensive
article about round three written by
Peter Dodgers at a time round three
finished so I do recommend everyone to
read it so yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
probably with with a game from round
four of the 2013 candidates tournament
thank you